snitch on the toasts Oh snitch on the
toast snitch on the toast it wasn't as
sticky it wasn't as snitchy because like
you you are like 75% of the snitches so
like I couldn't really hold the boat
seventy-five percent that's that's
generous towards you because I really
bring up I'm just like full snitch I'll
finish all the time the do you mean the
twenty five percent is generous I'm just
always snitching out on you and and all
you have to do is just be there even
even if you're not there I'm texting you
I'm snitching yeah that's true you are
by the 10% you are the snitch your
counselor snitch I'm so excited that
you're here it's always a fun time with
the snitch we have so much to catch up
but now we have a list I feel like I
haven't been here in a week but it's
only been four days because we did do a
show on Friday with Olivia did you catch
it
um I watched like a couple minutes but I
was on the train home and I was asleep
the whole time so how was your trip to
Boston
yeah it was good it was it was fraught
with peril well I actually do know that
it was fraught with peril because I
edited and put together the behind the
scenes video for our patreon channel so
the whole time the scenes were sending
me clips from backstage so that we can
make behind-the-scenes video for the
patreon members so actually do know how
treacherous it was it was very true and
we thank you for your service we thank
you for taking like in addition to your
many jobs for also creating content for
us for the patreon so if you guys want
to watch that video feature not calm
some morning toast also my home tour is
there did you wash my home tour yeah I
keep I text you every time you post on
patreon cuz like I have the patreon
hooked up to my podcast but I don't have
it like on like my phone but yeah sorry
so I every time she uploads letting him
okay he like my home tour I did actually
except with Theo like dying but aside
from that was that not the scariest
thing ever
where was your razor I don't know he
must have got it like off the ledge in
the bathtub or something I thought I
talked proofs my home I saw and I
cleaned everything for the home tour
right but I guess I didn't see like the
razor that was caught in like the shower
yeah curtain who knows oh my god that
could have been so bad like I don't want
to think about it well Ramat eyes if you
guys don't know what we're talking about
go watch the episode and please don't
call dog services animal control animal
control so what a weekend it has been
how was your weekend what did I do
you came back from Boston has left a lot
rocky - I went to Keith Urban in Kelsea
Ballerini
and it just was so great like I just
love country concerts there's like
nothing like them there's nothing like
that feeling that you have when you're
at a country concert and everything is
okay in the world no totally and like I
love Keith Urban and like I just didn't
realize have any of his songs like I
knew
did he play all the hits like even from
that album from way back he played a
song from 1999 doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo sounds
really really yeah that's yes yeah I'm
reading deeper than I've ever done and
it sure feels good to finally feel the
way I do yeah you did play that song
that's the best one I want to love
somebody love somebody like you that was
a nice harmony you had a good time
substances healing goodness just feeling
good she's so tired you look really hard
first name I know what it's like I
didn't know I didn't sign up for this
and then it just kind of happened
and like whatever I'm happy it's like
great that's how like all great things
happen in how all great you know
entrepreneurial businesses start so like
maybe from this like you start you know
your own like assistant operations
business tour management business you
never know where but you just keep your
nose to the grind I am but now we have
like two weeks off and it's like we
don't have another show to like November
7th right the day after their birthday
and then I don't really have any like
schoolwork these next two weeks so I'm
just gonna take it easy that's I'm glad
I'm happy for you and then we have
Olivia's Bachelorette I'm so excited by
the way like I know we just had a
vacation but I need another one and I'm
really excited to like go and lay and
just let loose I'm excited for you to
let loose because you did on my backside
no you're kidding no and you were so and
you were so there but now that I know
that like mentally you don't have
midterms already back I'm excited for
you
I'm scared cuz if that was me in the
Bahamas with something holding me back
but I don't know it's gonna happen Miami
I kind of lost my [ __ ] that Friday and I
would have stolen sham sham planes and
ticket antiquities
do you ever see holiday in the Sun a
hundred years and there's trying to find
Champlain Champlain stolen antiquities
that's what you would have done that's
what we would have done but anyways
we're here my birthday's in a week which
is shocking I just realized that
Halloween is tomorrow we are going to
have a very spooky episode for you guys
but we
plan that yet so give us some time I
can't believe like two days from now is
November it's just everything life is
like I know this month flew by but I
can't say I've been happy about it no
and now like I can't say I'm happy my
birthday is next week I just don't feel
like emotionally prepared
I yearn oh you're never emotionally
prepared for your birthday no but
sometimes you're so excited for your
birthday like you're counting down the
days and I'm not counting
I'm counting up the days like I need
like a little more time I mean my
birthday dress hasn't been delivered all
so I'm not really even doing anything
germs
I ordered a really cute dress for my
birthday dinner even though it's like
just dinner with our family like very
low so but I've been thinking about that
dinner
right yeah I need to be so good this
week me too so then just so that
everything tastes better at that dinner
yeah Italian feast we're having four
that's all I really wanted for my
birthday was delicious pasta and we were
talking before the show you don't know
what to get me for my birthday I have no
idea what to get her for I mean
everybody knows that I want to Gucci bag
but I'm not gonna ask that of a snitch
yeah but I don't know I I know that ever
like this is the most annoying thing to
say be like I really don't want anything
I just look like a little some some like
for like an Instagram ads yeah sure like
a little picture of Theo that sparkles
one way and is a picture like a pillow
did you see that I got that for Claudia
oh no okay I'm gonna get you picture of
Zach no no I'm just saying like
something from an Instagram ad that's
what I'm saying
okay yeah you don't have to break the
bank seriously I just want you to be
there for me like emotionally and
physically on my day okay yeah you'll be
but days it on it's time to choose day
okay in a week from today
oh it's actually in a week from today
what's your class schedule like on
Tuesday I pass straight from 9:30 to
3:15 but you know it's flexible can you
come to the toast for my birthday that
would be a nice gift uh yeah I think so
I this is Snitch this isn't I can't work
on Tuesdays Peter Krause I'm coming on a
Tuesday no technically I come on there
wait listen itch I can't work on
Tuesdays hey snitch I need you to host
Mitch on the terrace on Tuesday I can be
there well no because I can't commit
every single Tuesday I can't miss class
every single day but I can some Tuesdays
I understand but I just have to present
and I'm pretty sure to this Thursday not
next Tuesday so I should be good you
should be great and we just gotta get
you graduated we're gonna ask you all of
your class questions after like our Q&A
but one question that I saw or wasn't
really a question that I just think
would be the most amazing idea is that
all the toasters they want to come to
your graduation and I think
should host a graduation I think that we
should do a graduation like party
because honestly I got it I got enough
tickets for our whole family
no you know I don't and once you sign
I'll set it out no no you're coming
[ __ ] there's nothing on the only thing
that I hate more than school is a
graduation like I can't even tell you
I didn't choose an exciting graduation
because we've been waiting for this day
really [ __ ] long time that's true but
like sitting through a graduation is
pure treachery
like I didn't even want to go to my own
graduation and if you remember like they
called my name I walked onstage got my
diploma and walked off the stage yeah
and we went and we left and we fled the
scene that's what I'm gonna do speaking
of I I'm going to Colgate this weekend
and I'm excited but if any Colgate admin
or students are watching and you guys
want to roll out the red carpet for me
like I will not stop you um but I'm just
really excited for a fun fall weekend
yeah and it's so nice up there it is
hopefully the weather holds is it
supposed to it's actually supposed to be
like 60 on Thursday that upstate gets a
little colder that's true do you know
anybody who's currently there I know a
few people okay like I know some names
that I don't know them I'm in the frat
party like mood right cuz my reunion
weekend is in the spring and like that's
gonna be the party this I just kind of
want to like tour the grounds Zach never
has never been coming no it's just a fun
weekend with amongst friends oh really
and Becky and Dana are going with our
men and it's just gonna be like a fun
weekend to show them around isn't it
that's really cute thanks I'm glad you
approve um speaking of cute weekend's I
was just in Austin again have you ever
been no no but I've heard it's like lit
it is it's very Nashville vibe success
except that I didn't go to like the
Nashville area which is called Sixth
Street just because like I'm so mature
now but it's very like hipster it's very
weird and they're saying is keep Austin
weird and you know what you guys are
saying is keep Austin weird yeah it's
weird
they're doing a good job though because
it's very weird like everywhere it's
just like food trucks like it's just oh
yeah me it's so it's so weird and you
guys are doing a good job of keeping it
weird what's going on with the water oh
my god how weird is so we get there and
everyone was like by the way you have to
bring your own you should bring bottled
water because there's a water
contamination from the flood maybe
basically their whole water system all
of the waters have been mixing so that
means shrinking water river water sewage
perhaps so you can't drink the tap water
so while the restaurants they use
bottled water but there are some things
that you can't get at restaurants like
coffee
if there
papi is hooked up to the threesome so
getting coffee in Austin was literally
like trying to get drugs like there were
signs on all the restaurants they're
like we have coffee or we don't have
coffee so ultimately my hotel had coffee
when I went to get coffee elsewhere it
was like I was just that's such a weird
problem isn't that weird like it's 2018
but then one of the toaster said that
yes the water is contaminated but it's
not that poisonous like she accidentally
drank some and the bacteria levels are
really low it's just like gross to think
about and maybe someone could get sick
but it's not like the plague
right no but it's really affecting their
town it's so weird I mean yeah of course
on the weekend that I go of course but I
was drinking a lot of topo Chico right
which is this sparkling water I don't
know if you can get into New York you
probably can get it shipped here but
like you can't buy it like in a Duane
Reade right do you see Cappy I tagged
you in it I said you tell you I wrote a
Jackie over albums you sent this oh my
god Kathy is Luke Holmes's manager and
at the same time that I was reading
about topo Chico he posted a picture of
a shipment of topo Chico saying the best
stuff and it really is the best stuff
remember when I think Stinney on Friday
night and I think oh yeah and I think
money
oh my god yeah that was heavy vain
journey yeah of course like Annie bang
we're like you think you see the light
of death like the tunnel of death it's
similar to stubbing at oh it's okay it's
the same thing it's like you're helpless
there's actually nothing you can do and
you have to wait for that the robbing
pain to go away you have like four
minutes of judger pain and that's
happened to me my hotel may happen to be
facetiming with snitch thank God and it
was like I was in my far head I was like
like oh my god it was so funny like she
was like laughs crying and like her face
looked so weird because her forehead
couldn't move so it was like the
weirdest thing ever and I would check
your face that's what it looks like when
like Kim laughs on car - yeah I was like
where she's like well it causes her pain
- laughs cuz her foreheads not moving
even though she pretends like she's
allergic to Botox
speaking of Kim our sister has been
touched by the grace of God literally by
the grace of God she looked like an
angel she really did like the whole
picture is amazing when Claudia gets
back she will talk about it but Claudia
met our Queen Kim last night they took
an amazing picture where they both look
incredible
yeah like that never happens like a pair
of equals you know what happens to me
when I meet celebrities oh my god she
does this thing yeah like this nasally
like I have been Vegas smile I look like
such a dweeb in every single picture it
happens in every single picture I look
so lame that I can't even post it like
but I love vehicle but one oh my god I
look like such a little loser we have to
talk about Olivia culpo we'll get there
we will get there we'll get to the past
I stories but we just wanted to catch up
I just feel like I need to catch up with
the toasters catch up with the snitch
because I haven't seen you all weekend
and I'm looking forward to a week of
symmetry and an hour and a half of
century I'm here but it was also a
really sad weekend
you have the news out of Pittsburgh like
talk about a pit burg yeah no that was
like horrible work up to that news on
Saturday morning that someone went into
a synagogue on the Shabbat morning like
be more evil and he's already gunned
down a bunch of elderly Jews like even
talking about it makes me sick to my
stomach too because I just think about
like us and shul and like that happening
to us like that's [ __ ] terrible like
you could not be more defenseless when
you're praying I I think no and like and
you couldn't be more like a better
person like you're praying exactly I
can't think of anyone who deserves to be
murdered less than someone who's praying
nope yeah
an elderly Jew praying oh my god and one
of them was a hot and elderly Jew who
out I don't wish you a survivor yeah I
was seeing like conflicting roads and
out early Jew who outlived a holocaust
only to be killed by anti-semitism in
2018 in the United States like I can't I
can't I don't like talking about it like
gives me a bit know but there's things
that you can do there is a GoFundMe for
the tree of life synagogue that you can
donate to we put it on our stories but
we'll put it on the morning toast story
today yeah again and just honestly I
think like the most important thing to
do aside from like you know combating
anti-semitism wherever you can is just
like remembering their names ya know
like I just like try and like read their
names like like know as much about the
victims as possible and like that's how
they were like legacies can continue but
it's just like so awful and like this
isn't a sad show so I don't want to talk
about it for too long
like it really like tainted like a just
a dark cloud over just the Jewish
community and I think I'm really this
country because like something like this
happening in this day and age just is
horrifying
so on that note on that note are you
ready to get into the past oh and also
the world series
and our sister was there too claudia was
really like Forrest Gump this weekend
like just have every major event and the
Joe Jonas Jonas on to Stark
yeah so Joe Jonas dress up as Sansa
Stark this week for Halloween and the
one picture they have of them is like
Claudia's in it and it's army it's been
I'm like every like morning news show no
totally it was on CNN yeah and when I
was looking for news this morning I
almost pulled it as a story but I hate
to pull picked put typical stories that
relies so much on pictures for the
podcast listeners so but our sister was
just making news all weekend sitting in
the World Series I didn't see her on TV
but I heard that she did get on today I
didn't watch because I literally
couldn't care less about the World
Series I'm sorry the Red Sox won the
World Series that I know and I like I'm
pretty sure it wasn't a hard battle no
it wasn't a moment I was watching it was
a canned I was it was the games were
three to one so if Red Sox won this game
I would they win the World Series and I
was like well they're not gonna win the
game because then that cuts out two more
games of World Series that's like two
billion dollars that could be earned for
the MLB and and Network and maybe
they'll just pay all the players like 20
thousand dollars to put on another show
right but they didn't do that and so now
I don't like not that I was a conspiracy
theorist but that just seemed to make
sense to me like I wouldn't on but it
should they do that with football yeah
no but footballs just one gate like they
have seven games that's seven
opportunities to make like billions of
dollars so why would they cut that short
maybe because it's real that's nice that
something could be real in this day and
age yeah for sure okay here are the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast for these stories
our snitch centric because one when I
went to the bathroom snitch took some
initiative took my iPad and picked five
stories so not only are they snitchy to
the choruses but they're also subjects
that pertain to the Finch yes the first
story is really rocking your world I
know I like can't stop thinking about it
Olivia culpo is quote shocked by Danny
Amendola scusi Beach date with another
woman
Olivia Coco's boyfriend Danny Danny
Amendola wasn't exactly showing model
behavior this past weekend over the
weekend the NFL star and CBS sports
journalist Bianca Peters were spotted
some mating together in Miami Beach in
photos of the two Danny and Bianca are
seen cuddling the ocean and intimately
whispering while lounging on the beach
meanwhile olivia was working on the set
of Sports Illustrated
I'm suit addition in Australia now a
source tells enews quote Olivia's very
disappointed and shocked about the
photos that came out with Danny getting
cozy with another girl and despite the
risque appearance of the photos danny
has reassured Olivia that Bianca is a
longtime friend and they were just
catching up he has assured her that
nothing is going on between them and
that he is really happy with Olivia yeah
I struck the hair of my longtime friends
and canoodle in the ocean what do you
make of this I'm just so confused
because like he seems like someone who
doesn't isn't like really that kind of
guy who like is like football like
cheats on like girlfriend type thing he
seems like very like whole Simon normal
I don't really know him but like that's
just it I think the football athletes
having like they go hand in hand and I
think that's especially now that he's in
Miami
right and you're not like in cold New
England where all the girls are wearing
sweaters like now they're wearing
bikinis temptation is looming right but
like but I think it's a pill that you
need to swallow if you're gonna choose
to date an athlete like this is an
inconvenient truth I guess but like it's
just I also read in a different article
that like now they've gotten back
together like he was gonna propose soon
and like I just can't even imagine what
would happen if they got engaged but
like I think technically they're still
together right now and she's probably
figuring out which to but like mind you
this [ __ ] Bianca Peters is busy like I
don't know being a thought while Olivia
culpo is in Australia doing si swim like
um she's winning here even if she loses
Danny Amendola let's not forget that but
anyway so I went to Bianca Peters his
Instagram because you know I wanted to
troll and all her comments were shut off
and so I think she's getting the brunt
of it but I need to look at her
Instagram just to see what I really like
looks like Olivia Colman see what her
intentions are like is she an Instagram
thot
no she's a CBS sportscaster like she has
a legit job and like I don't know also
what I don't get is like just use your
brain like if you're both out in public
like and canoodling you're not trying to
hide something right that's what I don't
understand so maybe like what he's
saying is the truth I don't know or
maybe there's definitely a lot that we
don't know but I'm team Olivia because
as much as I love Danny Olivia like I
feel like she really tries with him
mm-hmm I'm like and she wants to go I
feel like she wants a real relationship
and like but then I've also seen some
blinds where it's like she does or
anything we saw was like a weird thing
about a credit card yeah there was one
that she said that she was
on a shopping spree with a credit card
that wasn't her own and wasn't her
boyfriend but like a year or so good for
her yeah also like that cause means like
her managers can I borrow it
no that wasn't right but I'm saying like
if that's the worst thing we've seen and
all the blinds that we've never read
about Olivia like right she's she's fine
yeah I'm confused about their
relationship like where it stood where
it stands now what level of like you
know you do your thing I'll do mine you
think that's what it it like I think
it's it's possible that they like most
celebrity relationships like okay
they're not open but it's just like
being a celebrity it's just different
and you right you have to recognize that
especially with like athletes but if
they do have like a Don't Ask Don't Tell
sort of policy like you don't do it in
public on the beach right that's the
part that's confusing and that's the
part that either makes it mean things
that it's an innocent thing or that they
weren't really fully together anymore
right
but then that article says that Danny
like reassured Olivia that blah blah
blah I don't know but then she posted to
her story well first when the pictures
first came out she tweeted Wow
and then she posted her story yesterday
of her being in Australia like killing
it like new day and new beginnings which
is like very cryptic and then when she
Instagram with the snake yes he said
this goes out to all the snakes Sade
Sade true shutting but I feel like she's
like so nice but like she's like you
she's so nice but when like someone like
crosses her she is a [ __ ] in a good way
in a good way
like when she needs to be she's like
really yeah no you once like it takes a
lot for me to get to a level the ones
not at that level it's like hell hath no
fury like a jacket scorned hell hath no
fury well we're gonna continue to be
updated by you because I feel like you
like Olivia culpo and Danny Amendola are
interesting because either you're Marga
wash right and they are like endgame or
you're someone who like really doesn't
even know who these people are so there
aren't that many like fans and new sites
who are dedicated to the minutiae of
this story that's true you really are
the leading expert on I'm Olivia and
Danny I know I like know their entire
timeline right so we're gonna continue
to get updates from you what they're
posting continues and things on
Instagram whether or not they on
follow each other I think they didn't
follow each other well he never followed
her which is weird an epitaph I never
understand one like well there was a
time when he had an Instagram but he
never posted
he just had followers and he only
followed Olivia right now that's not a
thing that was pre breakup number one
and then he unfollowed her and then he
just never followed by her again I
haven't checked but I saw somewhere that
she unfollowed him oh I saw that too but
you have to verify for yourself right
because people just make I know some
people don't like know how to check but
some people don't like I don't like to
say like oh they impoundment you go and
check and no they did in so I don't know
what I don't know it's hard but no it's
really the weirdest thing don't know how
to check maybe they're blocked by one of
them and they don't realize know like
whatever whatever
we'll check we'll figure it out and we
will continue to be updated by this
niche but in the meantime Olivia culpo
is down in Australia like shooting for
SI Swim rookie Rookie
I just she's a grotto oh my god what
would you do if she were on the cover
who do you think I don't know who's
gonna be on the cover
honestly because last year it was that
girl Danielle herring and she was a
first year right I think so so I don't
think they'll do another first year I
would have to be someone oh well Olivia
culpo still with tech mean she wouldn't
be a first year I guess she'd be like a
second year a yeah
i don't know i don't i think i don't
think it could be like a celebrity like
it exists not a celebrity but how they
did like Ronda Rousey one year like
Ashley Graham oh not someone specific to
as I swim or they always couldn't just
fall back on Kate Upton which they loved
maybe a pregnant Kate Upton pregnant
Kate Upton on the cover as I swim I'm
calling it now speaking of things that
suppose like this I think that would be
like incredible groundbreaking on brand
because they just always put her on the
cover I don't know what to do and like
it would just bring so many barriers
like yeah pregnant sexy woman in a
bathing suit
well they hire a sexy woman in amazing
so you walk around right right so maybe
you just like go off of that you guys
I'm telling you I'm on to something
well speak honestly they might not have
even thought of it but if they see this
but when they when MJ sees them JJ sees
this when's gonna decide where he's
scary yeah do you think Olivia had to
work with him again I think so probably
oh no no I actually stopped the
photographer of who's doing it name is
Josie so no wait what was I guess oh
speaking of like things that we're
calling we work we kept talking
referring to all year when well
came on the show did you know yes wells
came on the show in Nashville a year ago
and we were talking about Heyman sara
highlands halloween costume and how it
was amazing and then he was like next
year we haven't even better costume plan
and he didn't say it on the show he told
us after and we gave clues it was very
gender-bending culturally relevant like
great costume and he told us that it was
Taco Bell where he dresses up as Belle
and she dresses up as a taco and they
stuck to it and they looked so cute so
fun I wish that we burned it down
somewhere so we could have proven that
we didn't know but if you go back and
listen to all of our clues we didn't
know so don't really think anybody and
also that's the best time to think of
Halloween costumes is right after
Halloween you think of what you should
have done and then write it down write
it down I have a note of Halloween
costume yeah even though I'm not
trusting up this year I'm just like I'm
so tired
I have no Halloween plans I would only
dress up to like take a picture and like
pretend to go somewhere and come home
I'm pretty sure that's what I did
Kylie looked at me yeah but I'm pretty
sure she dressed up like in her room
took pictures and leten took it off I
think that's what she does every day
that's true so at least I think it was
premium IAS and [ __ ] stormy looked so
cute and like really she really I feel
like is inspiring people to have babies
is showing that like being a mom is so
incredibly rewarding like for
emotionally and like for the content but
who needs a baby boom when you have
Kylie Jenner
Kylie Jenner is the baby exactly okay
moving on to the next story something
else that shook the world last night
cardi B just issued a ten-part dressing
gown of Nicki Minaj on Instagram okay
this this whole thing is so wild and the
easiest way for guys to totally
understand is just to go to cardi B's
Instagram and watch all our videos but I
know you don't have time for all that
I'm the latest episode of her beat Swan
queen radio show which air today Nicki
Minaj once again brought up the skirmish
she got into with cardi B at the
Harper's Bazaar ikons party the one
where cardi allegedly threw a shoe at
her in the version of events presented
today Minaj said her not her friend
Raleigh beat cardi sass really bad which
included punching her in the head
numerous times and causing her injury
that Minaj was actually upset at her
friend for savagely kicking the tar out
of her industry rival she also adjust
the rumor that she leads cardis phone
number to fans so they would target her
with harassment saying she's never even
had cardis number to get out
well cardi B has apparently been
informed Minaj's latest loose talk and
emphatically rebutted Minaj's claims
in a ten part video series now posted to
Instagram okay you have to watch I worry
daddy I wish I knew that backstory when
I watch excited really understand what
was going on but like I doubt that cardi
got like the B [ __ ] beat out of her
right and so basically the thesis of
cardies of cardis rebuttal she's taking
on every Nicki Minaj point one at a time
first of all she takes on the point
about rah Ali beating her up and
basically cardi asks do you want to be
the victim or do you want to be the
gangster because Nicki Minaj is
positioning herself like oh wow cardi
attacked me this that but then also it
is like cardi and [ __ ] like right my guy
beat her up so bad that I actually felt
bad then they also leaked Hardy's number
cardi's talking about that
cardi talk about how Nicki claimed just
was gonna sue her and cardi was like I
wouldn't sue anyone I ain't no snitch
did you see the little mix thing yes
then little mix involves themselves
saying this was so stupid right they
just want to they just want to be like
rising tide raises all ships because
cardi B was talking about a few tracks
where they went to cardi verse cardi
first and a few tracks where they went
to Nicki first there's a G easy track
that they took to Nicki that Nicki
didn't like so they gave it to cardi and
then Nicki yelled at her Matt barked at
her management saying that they should
have given her the song but really she
had at first she just didn't choose it
exactly so Nicki Minaj's recently on a
little mix song that um isn't as good as
it could be I'm enjoying it more than
you are listen to it once it it like it
um and I like a little bit little mix
has inserted themselves into the
situation by saying that they went
straight to feel like he like started
like show receipts and [ __ ] well they
started show them like text messages
that like we're look totally fake also
little mix like they're a great band but
they definitely don't have a group chat
because they definitely don't like each
other okay also like if you're smart
like yes making Minaj is huge but like
don't go after cardi because she's like
on the rise so like if you really want
to break into America's music industry
like you want to go against one of the
top earners right I'm you wouldn't get
go against someone that like is doing so
much for your craft do you know yeah
like go out go against someone who's
like a talentless hack there's more than
enough to go around I'm sure you could
find someone I thought that was so weird
like just shut up yeah I mean you should
watch the videos cuz it's really so
crazy but they are really long and like
but I understood cardis me to speak her
side of the story because it felt like
she was trying
to take the high road and choose the
meanwhile like Mickey Mouse just like
selling merch around the situation and
my cell works around the situation yeah
that's what I saw and like just trying
to be like gangster but also like making
a car nice party like says such smart
things sometimes she really does like
he's not as stupid as people think she
is like I don't even think anyone thinks
that she's stupid Oh fine I don't know I
thought that but like she's like says
that it's such a smart thing to say like
choose whether or not you want to be the
gangster or the victim like yeah yeah
yeah I love her I love her she was just
showing all these receipts like all
these text messages all these phone
numbers she leaked thankies phone number
because Nikki's people leaked her phone
number and like they leaked everyone's
phone number when they get into a fight
with them that's a - setting on her
video anyways then after this whole rant
Nikki like posted a tweet like like
let's move on from this and cardi posted
the tweet and was like happy to move on
so I guess we're moving on from this and
personally I'm glad me too I'm like just
like sick of hearing about it I'm sick
of hearing about a two-minute it's just
too much for me to keep up with and I
like both ladies I know but now this
whole thing has made me not like Nikki
I'm team cardi when it comes to this but
I do so I do so like Nikki but I haven't
been liking Nikki's music yeah the last
music I liked was her pink what's about
pink pretty got an album and then like I
did not like Queen was that the name of
her last album wasn't I it was uh it was
it was a queen I don't even know it was
I'm pretty sure I didn't even yeah I
mean I love pink print oh oh my god it's
like and and that will hold me over
until the next album like you're allowed
to have a job like that's fine but
that'll take me to the next album but
her like getting into like the trenches
with cardi B is job not doing anything
for anyone
bad move bad move and like cardi B is
here to stay
I know a what I'm just keeps like
churning out me look like money like
people are loving it right and she has
her own songs she's featured on songs
like she is doing so much it's not just
like she's not a one-hit wonder
whatsoever whatsoever and I like it it's
like this song of the year
[Music]
I didn't get into that song until like
way too late me that just as I'm old I
don't think that maybe maybe actually if
you didn't either and you're a young
person yeah and I just didn't know that
that's where we were all going right and
then it was like forced on me and I was
like okay right and it was like playing
at this wedding I was at this weekend
actually yeah it took you this long no
no no like it was playing at this
wedding and I was out this weekend and
now I'm realizing like how like now I'm
at the peak of how much I like it
whereas people were there four months
ago oh yeah you know yeah you're
definitely but they did something cool
like the band was playing I like it and
then the DJ transition didn't like
started playing it so that's how they
transition from bands DJ if anybody was
looking for any transition suggestions
which I know you turn you tune in to
this show for yeah just transition
suggestions a lot of mouths tongue
twisters today yes and planes
antiquity's transition suggestions are
you ready for next Tori I'm ready hit
man this is a story that the snitch
chose that I actually don't know if I
would have seen Christiano Ronaldo
overtakes Selena Gomez as the most
followed Instagram user thank Lord
Selena Gomez's the least deserving human
to have the most followed people but
most amount of followers on Instagram
well Cristiano Ronaldo I don't know like
how much like sure I don't really like
here where it like weren't we're just so
not his like audience right but it's
fine I'm just glad that it's someone
that's not Felina Oh Selena never posted
like it's not fair to have the like
throne if you're not gonna use it right
and like when she does post like it's
clearly not her and it's like all such
like PR stuff coach sponsorships
coca-cola like II never I actually just
about I saw that like yesterday and I
unfollowed Selena I was like I don't I
don't know if I still follow her I think
I'd go back and forth sometimes but I
need to unfollow because I don't want to
contribute to her being number me
neither and like if it should be any
like singer it should either be like
Taylor Swift or ariana grande or and
then Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian
really should be number one because this
is her job like all she does it's
dedicated to the premium content did you
see that picture of her like vagina on
her vagina but like vaginas yeah there
was no like was vagina season yeah but
it wasn't like a vagina yeah it was like
some
it was something else but not a vagina
it was like I don't know what it was we
have to call like an Anatomy expert I
know I think it's because like if if
they were aligned at what has been unity
exactly right this was just supposed to
be like maybe our caricature I think it
was supposed to be art it was weird but
yes goal
Cristiano Ronaldo is now the most vile
person on Instagram having recently
surpassed Selena Gomez as oppressed I'm
Ronaldo has 144 million three hundred
thirty-eight thousand six hundred fifty
followers - Gomez is 144 million three
hundred twenty-one thousand twenty-nine
followers so this could really change
and maybe some people without this story
and like unfollow Salinas and go follow
Selena just to get her back up so I'm
sure could go back and forth but this is
a big deal like the most solid person in
the world is a is a high honor to be
bestowed totally and it's so crazy it's
not really someone that you would think
it would be no I guess Selena Gomez you
like she like me have sense just because
she's like she's a berry she's a big
star but also you have to keep in mind
she's very international star like
Taylor Swift it's a huge star and she's
international star but like she's also a
very American english-speaking star like
Chris Selena Gomez like also speak
Spanish like also has songs in Spanish
like that's true that and Cristiano
Ronaldo is a very international star
yeah and I do think Kim is a very
international star I think so too
I don't know it's just so interesting
that it's him when you said it would be
Taylor Swift or who ariana grande Oh
Ariana Grande's 132 I checked last night
so she's not like I mean she's
definitely like kind of far but now
she's flying apart and also I think what
hinders ariana grande and I personally
don't follow her is her content it's
like a little annoying but like I would
rather someone who's content it isn't
all annoying because should they post a
lot rather than someone who doesn't it's
not like she posts odd it's like
everything is sideways or upside down
and cryptic and blurry and like foggy
you know her but her aesthetic is like
it's like spooky I know but like it I
love her like I didn't love her speaking
of Ariana Grande wicked wicked do you
guys watch wicked I don't know how I got
an answer from you I have the comments
on here yeah we'll see in the comments
um I watched it I didn't and it was
funny because when it started to act was
like is this um not
I was like no it's not alive it's just a
special honoring wicked week and I think
nobody knew what to expect like what the
[ __ ] I was thinking when I was watching
it like wow like NBC is like it was let
me say right it's like so in tune to
like no to do this she's not I mean like
no one would ever think about it that
way they're like do like a 15 year
anniversary of wicked weather like they
again idina menzel and like Kristin
Chenoweth like that's honestly like it's
their berry in June right and right
before Halloween like on the 15 year
anniversary of when it premiered and I
did I knew that wicked was like huge and
you know record-breaking but I guess I
didn't realize that it was really like
how big it was because when he came out
we saw it we were kids we saw it with
the original cast thank God we saw video
right yeah yes it was look at deal I
know and now it's like I want to see it
again but how do I see it with padena
and Kristen exactly
and all those patinas and Kristen's that
came out last night were really cute
that was a really cute idea yeah so
let's talk about everything um if you
watched it you know and if he didn't
there's no spoilers and it was just like
a one-hour special where they paid
tribute to some of the best songs and
some celebrity fans of the show so we
had pentatonix which was so good which
was so good I've been liking Penta to
used to like I was like what a cover
band but no they're really really good
they're really good but they like switch
out their members on us and they think
we don't know no there was only one and
it was like news like one of them he was
like Jewish and he like didn't want to
do it anymore he like wanted to like Oh
be like a normal normal guy and so he
left pentatonics and then they replaced
him with what I don't know there used to
be a blonde girl did she just dye her
hair
maybe I'm pretty sure that that was like
they only switched that one member
because he left like they had to okay I
just was like but the only guy that I do
know is that one do you know the blonde
haired one for some reason superfruit
with that the blonde haired one and the
guy who was singing Kristin Chenoweth's
apart they used to they were a do
welcome superfruit things to make videos
on YouTube oh and where they did a
cappella the guy who's saying Christian
shadow as part was like so good like it
was crazy
no they were they're so good and like
they are are real like Glee and I was
talking about how much Glee and wicked
have like intertwine everyone was saying
like like just like you were part of my
stories or in the toasters they were
like this is just making me wanna watch
Glee it's crazy how both of them were
like main characters on Glee both
Kristen energy
and like how much respect Brian Murphy
clearly has for Glee but also like I
really they should have believed a shell
should have been there to sing a song
yeah obviously not trying gravity but
like something because like she like she
brought wicked to like the younger tenet
for generations yes um overall I loved
it there were a few things like I would
have personally done differently um but
I just I'm glad that they're doing stuff
like this because it's just fun for the
whole family truly like the first song
that they did where they showed that the
cast doing it's like what's that song I
didn't need that song I didn't need that
there are these they wanted to have the
cast in it I'm assuming like the current
cast yes but you give us dancing through
life like how you know one [ __ ] plays
dancing through life I think it's
because it's almost eight minutes long
and like we don't have that kind of time
no there are so many commercials how
could they but like it's an amazing song
I don't know dancing through life down
at yazd us with pony because dust is
what we come to nothing matters like
knowing nothing matters also I'm so
off-key it's crazy
um okay ariana grande was the best was
the I watched a whole bunch of times
before I went to sleep
oh my god I stood in Edina were amazing
but Ariana's are kind of annoying she
was but that's her character so I get it
but also when she brought that girl on
stage like and that girl was holding her
phone like I was just like this this is
a travesty like it's like it's like
chewing guys it's almost as if she was
chewing gum like it was she was just
holding her phone in her hand like oh my
god I I was so annoyed and it's like
everything else was so perfectly planned
in time than choreograph it's like we
couldn't choose someone who knew to put
their phone down right and she wasn't
even dressed up with like wicked I don't
know the whole thing in China it took
someone else this one to take a selfie
she didn't even click she's getting
click right and that's okay for that
person yeah I were like she didn't even
take the picture so they were like if
you click just like that but overall I
feel like it was a very good updated
touch to to Wiccan right
idina menzel change defying gravity way
too much yeah I mean I still thought it
was good but like I when I was watching
it I was like this isn't what I wanted I
wanted like I like how when they update
the tunes and they go I wanted it to
sound like how it sounds on the
soundtrack i me - she was like over
singing it a little bit and I get I get
how it's it's so easy to do that you
know right that you people are here to
hear but you also want to give people
something a little bit different than
what they just
two on the soundtrack all the time but
it was just a little too different for
me she sounds amazing and and she is
amazing but I wasn't really there was
just a little there was too much change
yeah and then Adam Lambert which like he
was fine but Ariana Grande like and like
also just to know what - what she went
through to get there and then like she
gave the performance of a lifetime a
lifetime and it's like I just and she
was so into it - like and when she took
her mic out of the stand like she just
like I could watch her perform it's like
literally all day I'm probably gonna
watch it after this I saved it into my
Instagram like I love her love for
wicked right and it just made me like
wonder like where were some more like I
could have done with some work at
sovereignty cameos that we're in tune
right also I hope that they do like a
wicked live at some point and I hope
that yourself about where's she taking a
breath alive she could've been Glinda or
it should be dump Cameron alpha by
ariana grande oh my god 11:11 make a
wish for wicked live with Ariana
Grande's alphabet and done Cameron is
out that would be like a dream and their
friends because they didn't hairspray
together put it out there it could
happen oh my god Lee last night did well
and now like I knew it
lowest of Cameron I can't wait to see I
can't wait had red live IB she's not to
say that I said that like a minute ago
Beadon here
no I didn't I saw I can add for it who's
Vanessa Hudgens is in it but that's a
Hudgens obvious Tinashe yeah
Kol settles like feature and she's not
even though we I saw the ad in the car
with you yeah she's not even like a
character which is like bye okay um it's
I didn't see the whole thing so I don't
know oh my god I have dementia it's
coming to Fox in January yes it's just
exciting I can't remember the other
characters but like I'm pretty sure they
did a good job with the cast but what
should be a big holiday live coming out
there always is on Fox or something by
the way you know til crazy he's like her
NBC greatest showman like came out like
a year ago
I know and it's like been just
positively changing my life ever since
ever since oh my god November 16 great
shimon reimagined like what's already
most excited for
from now on Zac Brown Band for me oh
[ __ ] okay um there's a few things I'm
weirdly so excited for panic at the
the ratio me to click I think it's gonna
be like it's gonna be amazing and I
think it might be my aside from a
million dreams but we already got it
right that would have been what I was
most excited for the greatest show was I
think one of my favorite songs on the
album it's just such a feel-good song
and oh it's just whatever I need to do
like it always makes me like ready to do
it right but then also come alive just
Glenn it's home live Jess Glynne Jessica
Lynne years and years Oh are we gonna be
okay I don't think so I really don't
like I'm just like I don't know what we
did to deserve like for someone to just
like it realized that they need to do
this and give it to us we never get what
we want and now we're getting in I just
I literally can't believe it we're
getting it though and we deserve it for
all of our like year of hustling in
silence and working for this movie and
like just pushing it out there with a
thing and with no reward no no we worked
for 25 everybody wrote it off right you
critics Patsy compulsion didn't know we
were out here doing this and like we've
just been working because we love it so
much and like this is the universe
giving us a gift saying thank you for
the work you've done for the great so
now that I love pentatonix they're doing
a bonus track for it which is just like
I wish the boat the reimagined version
of this is me was like it's with Kesha
Keawe Missy Elliott which will be really
good but I I could have done with like a
whole like an idina menzel version like
something just completely different
right like why keep que Ella if you're
not keeping on Ke$ha I'm done with
Kesha's yeah we heard Cash's and Kayla's
and which is left much to be wanted
desired I'm just so [ __ ] excited like
that's gonna just change my world
and speaking of worlds changing back to
wicked sorry it's really crazy how like
one Broadway show really changed the
lives of idina menzel and Kristin
Chenoweth like thanks we just the whole
Broadway people and now and then they
became just huge huge actresses yeah I'm
like Kristen Chenoweth remember we saw a
foundry Bocelli yeah and that sort of
thing I guess it happened with Hamilton
too but it doesn't happen that often
where you like and your vannhansen
actually mean it happens more often no
but I'm saying it happens now I think
because of wicked perhaps like wicked
like started the trend perhaps and you
know what I always think about that song
for good is amazing oh my god but change
for the better
yeah I need to think of the lyric I was
gonna say something even when I remember
the first time I saw it again change for
the better because I knew
you I have been changed and I always
thought it was gonna say forever because
it rhymes with fur the better yeah but
um it never liked that whole song in
that moment was so great because like
all of their lives have been changed for
the better because of each other and
where they were and it was just oh it
was so good you guys if you didn't get a
chance to watch it it's probably on
demand enjoy it it's just good clean fun
for the whole family
yeah and it's like how do you get
invited to stuff like that I think about
this all the time because there's all
these specials or like these like
private concerts or like the CMT
Crossroads like how do you get in how do
you get in there like how'd you find out
about it so like they like sell tickets
I think you have to be like in the
theater like Broadway community well bad
I'm like email it did you watch the same
teen crossroads with Zac Brown man and
Shawn Mendes no I
I watched it through your story no oh my
god like it was so good it's such a good
pairing and like I love Shawn Mendes
because he's just like so successful and
like didn't go the route of Justin
Bieber you know yeah I mean like no he's
not gonna it's cuz he's like from Canada
I'm telling you Justin Bieber from
Canada oh [ __ ] but how are we gonna get
you on a date with Shawn Mendes I don't
know well this is me but you need to go
on a date with him like for your career
and for I know but like oh my god I love
him so much the fact he's just so in
tune to like know that like Tim he chose
a crown band like they approached him
and they were like who would one do it
with and he did he was like background
man
I said his favorite song is obviously
colder weather but also I want crazy by
Hunter Hayes like I just don't
understand what we did to deserve Shawn
Mendes he's so wholesome and good I love
him they did such good songs like I just
can't okay I'll watch it okay that's
like easy watching you know well I'm
like to clean my apartment or exactly
for my next home tour just kidding I
haven't nothing's changed okay next
story Kylie Jenner surprises mom Kris
Jenner with a $250,000 red Ferrari ahead
of her 63rd birthday leaving sister
Khloe red-faced about her gift-giving
she's a self-made billionaire and on
Monday Kylie Jenner surprised her mom
Kris with a red Ferrari 488 ahead of her
63rd birthday 488 for the Queen she
captioned a video of Kris behind the
wheel of her new ride adding that it was
her quote dream car her sister Chloe
joked that she had clearly outdone her
on the present buying front and it seems
it would be pretty hard to be I mean
that's impossible to be also a good boy
who was red-faced
like her face her face
I can't believe she let like Kylie film
her and that's like what I love about
Kris is she will do anything for the
premium content for like she's really
she doesn't have like a lot of pride you
know yeah she lets herself be like what
like like I don't mind being the butt of
the joke
yeah and I'm so happy Vernon this is so
nice of Kylie and I just I love them so
much I feel like they love each other
obviously they love each other but you
know I mean yeah I feel like Kylie is
similar to Kim and that like she like is
one of the few that like loves and
respects her moms and like defers to her
and listens to her right I couldn't
agree more and my Kourtney definitely
doesn't right and you know what it's
also no coincidence why'd the two of
them have had the most success in their
career because they respect the KJ and
because they listen to the KJ and the KJ
has good advice like she like we regard
this of what you think about her like
all you need to know about Kris is like
what her daughter's like what's your
complet you know so whatever you think
about her like doesn't even matter
yeah like if you think she likes old
ASEC doesn't like I don't think she sold
the sex tape but you think she did I
don't I don't but like even if she did
like look where it got them totally
would you sell your daughter sex tape if
it meant that you and your whole family
we're gonna be like the most famous rich
people in the world and set for life
like don't have to talk to her first
yeah and be like like are you willing to
sacrifice this and if she said yeah we
can't but if she was like no mom don't
like that I wouldn't
okay that's fair yeah I'm sure Kim said
yeah oh for sure yes it was Kim's idea
yeah no I don't think any there's any
animosity there right uh I'm just happy
for Chris because like she just deserve
so much shine and I feel like she really
gets it around her birthday and the rest
of the year like she just gets the brunt
of it yeah totally um I love Kylie and
like I feel like now that she's a mom
she has even more respect for her mom I
couldn't agree more
and soon stormy is gonna buy be buying
Kylie cars with Kylie's money yeah but
Kylie's buying with her own money like
that's like so amazing I wonder what
Kourtney got Kris for her birthday
probably blaming pile of Doody a lump of
coal holistic vegan organic cool I
literally despise Kourtney so much like
I don't even know how to explain it like
I think about it often I need to make up
chat I meet I'm not caught up I haven't
like seen episodes I just don't like her
like I sometimes accidentally like her
pictures on Instagram and I'm like them
yeah because I just don't want
everything follow her damn you don't
follow her yeah I have oh I do I'm gonna
empower you should like I see her
pictures through enews eNOS is getting
crazy about their like they post so much
they live any time they just want to
like they want to be like the one
Instagram where every celebrities
picture that they posted is but like not
really like how all right but if I
wanted to see this person's picture it's
like I would follow them like you only
need to post news new like a
groundbreaking Instagram from a
celebrity not just like a cute thing
from their story like they posted a
picture I wanna succeed their story I
would follow that they posted a picture
of us today I have Sophia and Scott like
from Sophia's story and was just like
lovebirds
who cares I don't like your called any
news that's not a photo no but I feel
like their strategy is like their
mission like the one-stop shop for all
celeb news on Instagram you don't need
to follow any celebrities if you're
following news but it's like we do
follow celebrities we don't need to say
I don't need to see doubles agreed thank
you
um but Scott did cut his hair I guess
that was the news there I honestly I
really really like Scott Sophia me too
like so much I think she's like so hot
and like I love him and like he seems
happy and he's happy and normal and like
just like and it's like he's not he's
not sober but he doesn't want to be nor
does he really need to be he's not I
don't think is like yeah he doesn't seem
to be like out of that room are right I
really like I'm like she lets him like
live his life in the way that he wants
you and she's there by his side so he's
not alone like here for it on all counts
yeah and I love how much you do follow
her yes she like loves with Lionel
Richie like her she loves her dad
I like should I post like his stuff and
she's like she's no proud daughter yeah
I guess she also doesn't have like that
much else going on right like I feel she
wasn't really model anymore yeah I feel
like she was the Twitter town at one
point until she started dating Scott's
like she feels like they thought that
way about like Haley Baldwin like now
that she's like marriage she hasn't
she's been working like way less I'm
here for you like maybe like the two of
them are also short so they had to like
date up I think Haley Bozeman's not sure
but I she's short for the for her for
the group really that's I think that's
why she's not like the Tori secret she's
not as tall as Kendall and Gigi
I love Haley Baldwin like aside from the
whole Justin Bieber of it all like I've
always loved her I think she's like
literally so beautiful yeah she is and I
think I think she's prettier than
Kendall and
and it was autumn I'm Gigi Abbey about
the Hadid I also feel like she does
really get surgery like Botox Arnie I'm
she wasn't Botox but I don't think she's
ever really gotten like work done yeah
no she definitely just has like inject
like maybe a Nozomi a cheek maybe a nose
job but like that's not that's
considered not surgery these which is so
crazy
speaking of Botox how crazy is my
forehead do it I just have like
quotations here which I like because
then I consume I don't where I still got
it so much expression so little time but
I was I was watching Hallmark as I fell
asleep the other night and I realized
that a lot of the Lee actresses like do
have the skinny brow line like they need
to be able to make that face so I don't
think I can be an on hallmark for
another six months okay but it's fine my
new dream is see an animated series but
also that way you can go to work without
makeup on based on the counselor in the
camper yeah how do we get that
you just got your meme oh look I guess
we'll go talk get to camp source Mitch
in a minute let's get through the rest
of the stories but I love her she's my
favorite counselor Hilary Duff and
Matthew koma welcome daughter Banks
violet she's absolute magic quote a mini
Lizzie McGuire has arrived Hilary Duff
and boyfriend Matt coma welcomed their
first child together on October 25th
according to their birth announcement on
Instagram Monday quote Binks violet bear
this little bit has fully stolen our
hearts she joined our world at home on
Thursday afternoon and his absolute
magic Duff rode along with a portrait of
herself creating their Bailey cradling
their baby girl with coma the proud new
dad also shared the exciting news
writing banks violet bear 10 25 18 we
welcome a beautiful daughter liitle see
stir and best friend for life who could
not possibly be more grateful for a
growing family and for the orange who
makes it all possible
I get the orange part maybe that's like
his name for her so Hillary I don't know
orange
honestly banks is a really cute name for
a girl thanks violent yeah like I really
like it and normally I don't like cyber
games do you have names picked out for
your Leto to children no if you had to
pick like I like there's one name that I
love but I think Claudia called it and
she's definitely gonna happy having kids
before I am so I wonder what it is do I
know what it is I think so is it
something having to do with like our
family history yes okay then you now
know that I still don't with an R with
an R okay then I don't know
um I used to really like the name violet
like for a child but I think now it's
just like you tube done you know and
it's like names are tricky because you
want a trendy cloning because you want
your kids to be cool in school but then
when you get too trendy then you wind up
with like Apple Ethel and then Ethel
it's like everyone knows Ethel is 70 so
I feel like that's gonna be what happens
with like the name like Chloe for
example it's like in 50 years everyone's
gonna know that Chloe is 70 there's no
going to be no Chloe's in there not it's
a little too trendy Apple is not even a
trendy name it's just a weird name yeah
you know so you want something like
classic but also cool no you bumped up
in classic but original it's a hard line
to walk
yeah and is and I respect all the moms
out there who can settle on one name
yeah multiple kids so you can use a lot
of different names yeah that Macon's you
want I want a lot like I want to I
really but only for max but you never
know like how life goes Jerell so and
you just want healthy children really
totally you want for max max yeah
actually I want four not four yes yep or
is a great number but it also depends on
how the genders are coming out that's
like and I might have more or less kids
depending on how my gender I feel like
because like we're so girl heavy like
are the next generation is just gonna be
like men well also because the sex is
determined by the male so even though
our genes are like all female it doesn't
matter is it the other thing is how it
works is it both of us know the sex is
determined by the male I don't think
that that's right and I think this show
like I maybe like they have a higher
percentage but like she's definitely
like our part of the genetic process the
genetic process you know the genes like
the of the chromosomes
I don't know counselor I think you're
wrong I don't know counselor snitch
speaking of now we will launch into our
counselor snitch segment we also do need
to recap dynasty oh my god to that after
I get to all the questions for headline
because then if people haven't watch can
shut up um oh yeah so that people who
haven't watched can shut it off but you
guys if you are sleeping on dynasty like
you're wrong you're so wrong the first
season one is on Netflix and it
is a masterpiece masterpiece and the
second season is so good just it's like
usually the sophomore season like
Riverdale was slow and then I picked up
like it is so good like yeah it came out
it came out run it's the best show on TV
right I agree so weird for young people
yeah and also for old people but like we
don't have a lot of good it's like a
content yeah but it's like it's like
this generations like Gossip Girl just
no one knows about it yeah but it's also
like even smarter than Gossip Girl in
some ways yeah cuz Gossip Girl was
stupid and like Serena van der Woodsen
is no role model but Fallon Carrington
is a woman we can all get behind a boss
ass [ __ ]
like amazing clothing when we were in
high school everyone wants me Serina
but like Serena is a dumb [ __ ] and
makes the worst choices and if you were
trying to be Serena like I'm sad to
think about how your life turned out but
if you want to be like Stalin you're on
top of the world right now
congratula salad I love salad like I
love her I love the Lay's that place her
I love that Liz loves Fallon Blaze's
Instagram like you know she just loves
her job and like that's what I love I
like team choses when they they love
being on the show that is beloved I
agree and I just love the whole the
whole cat look at to it except for the
crystal of it all which will got tail
okay okay oh it's funny most of the
questions that we get for you are like
always the same but it is nice to get an
update like maybe things have changed
honestly my life hasn't changed at all
but what is your favorite fan Instagram
account first myth that was written by
Councillor snitch there's a new whenever
there's a new fan account like they go
so hope so hard at first yeah and it's
so like fun and funny and councillor
snitch is the Instagram account that is
turning out premium content right now um
also Jackie's meme og where they clip
all of my momochi stuff and do more um
you've just got me emoji I just
something that I updated my phone so now
you can finally respond yeah to the
camper I can how does it feel it's
really funny I still I like it I enjoy
receiving them more than I enjoyed doing
them you enjoy receiving them because
one question was on a scale of 1 to 10
how annoying are those videos zero oh
I'll tell you that's how I guess it's a
ones war it's one it's one they're so
fun they are regular it's [ __ ]
hilarious
interesting question are you gonna bring
assist a date to any
your sisters weddings like guys don't
you think you know no but like most
people do by the way not most people but
some people like when they go to a
wedding even if they're not dating
someone they'll like get a date on
tinder or something like that's how much
people's like can't be alone which is
crazy but like they'll get a date off
the street you like if you like bring
yeah yeah for a family members wedding
it's weird to bring a date that you're
not really dating because then like are
they in pictures yeah no that's weird um
but no the answer's no but if you want a
plus-one for my wedding like you can
definitely get one you can definitely
have one um
this must be a new toaster but what is
your major and when will you graduate
finally please my major is sociology and
I'm graduating in May and I literally
can't [ __ ] wait I have a question for
you say like something happened like
credits got swapped or you found out
like a class that was worth some credits
wasn't worth as much and like you
weren't able to graduate in May
like would you continue I would just
drop the [ __ ] out like I'm done I'm done
like I can't do it anymore
I hate school and then people come at me
and they're like you're so lucky to like
get an education but like I know that
and I'm very grateful but I can still
hate school I can still hate studying
and writing essays like I'm still a
normal human also the education that our
children are getting these days is
nothing to be proud of I couldn't agree
more
I'm no smarter now than I was when I
graduated high school
me I'm smarter like street smart and I
would have learned that either way
either right but education wise I
haven't learned anything and when I like
study I forget it the second I take the
test like I hate it I feel you sister
I'm sweating now
so logistics wise what are you gonna do
when Olivia moves cuz obviously your
roomie has been engaged and are losing a
roomie but gaining gaining a brother
that was my caption and it was an
amazing caption um so what are your
plans well I'm moving home to our
childhood home until I graduate because
like it's kind of in the middle of
everyone's leases so like there's no one
for me to like move in with right now
and then after graduation I'll probably
either move in with friends or stay at
home just because it's like so nice and
easy and like I just like don't really
have to
and I can't see you living with friends
like sighs yeah like snitching the gals
I know cuz like everyone annoys me and
it's like from what I've heard from you
like you're the you're like the mom of
the group which is so weird to think
about cuz you are the video let me get
this right here's a play it's not that
I'm the mom of the group
we're like I'm the planner and like I
take care of everyone which is that
crazy group but I'm also the one who
gets the most drunk so it's a weird
dynamic amiibos yeah here the person who
plans the trips like makes the
arrangements like I was never that at my
group of friends I wasn't the one that
like needed to be like hey like held
hands with right but I just would never
see you as that but like for our group
of friends like that was Sam like she
was on top of everything I can't believe
like you're the Sam of the group yeah
that's shocking stuff because to us like
you're you're sick exactly no yeah it's
weird
dear friends ever call you snitch um no
what's the most exciting part about
being on tour with Claudia I'm getting
all the miles and so I just became
became medallion status so in an amazing
answer so now I'm getting like all the
benefits and stuff so it's great also
please teach me your ways of balancing
life because college traveling for
tourists the toast intern having a life
how just how okay I don't really have a
life I'm not gonna lie like I really
rarely see my friends these days but how
do i balance it well I mean I don't
really like schools really taken like a
backseat I don't really go to my classes
but I do all my assignments they take
all my tests and I haven't gotten my
grades back yet but I can get my fine
and you just have to it's time
management and it's also like I'm a big
last-minute last-minute
Krammer so like you just you know you
just get it done and you have to take
time for yourself because I feel like
you spend enough time like just being
with yourself and like watching TV and
doing what you want that when you have
to do the things that you need to do you
don't feel deprived right that's why I
never really seen my friends cuz it's
like what I have the time off I want to
be alone and I want to be in bed and I
want to be watching Desperate Housewives
right I'm like they get that and I still
text them and then they come over and
they watch with you right that they
actually do right so that's fun a new
toaster alert can someone please tell me
why they call her the snitch okay I wish
there was an easy explanation I don't
know where it originates from but if you
know our family like we are the call
ourselves the Steen's that like is a
long joke from like a Taylor Swift song
so I was calling you like Steve
punishment a tiny niche and then I was
like time Shinichi
stitches snitches ain't like and then
that Nicki Minaj song which is why I
also have to love her forever [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] and they ain't saying nothing
a hundred [ __ ] gonna tell me
nothin i beez in the trap be-beez in the
trap so I would always say snitches
ain't [ __ ] and they ain't saying nothing
and then that just came snitches ain't
and now that's why snitch just ain't
like there never is in and that has to
do a lot with Nicki Minaj so for that I
will always love her I didn't even
realize that it how much she contributed
to the Stila culture
well it's but let's be real it was it
all started with Taylor Swift
I know started with Taylor so as most
wonderful things phone call from Oyster
Bay New York it's definitely span but
like stop don't they know is a this is
an amazing question break your sisters
from lease bridezilla to most bridezilla
so far it's it's not there because we
haven't gone to completion yet right and
like and Claudia was I'm nicely like
involved I like I don't really know like
it's like I'll be there for like like
through the dress and stuff like that
but like I'm out there when you're
planning right and I feel like you'll
get it sends like on the wedding day you
know cuz well Claudia was planning like
she was not a bridezilla whatsoever and
she really left us out of most of the
planning like over the time she was
right illa with the whole dress
situation but I would be too oh yeah
because that's that's the craziness of
the scene yeah but um I don't know I
can't really answer that I'm just not
informed enough to like know I also like
Olivia's planning and like I literally
have no idea what's going on with that
so I I just can't be a judge that's true
but you're just the Cinch
yep is it is it nice being the Cinch
it's nice being like so young yes like
everyone's taking care of you you have
jobs up the wazoo jobs up the wazoo
no it's it's nice being the snitch it's
a lot but it's nice it's a lot of
expectation true if you could be any
character on Riverdale who would you be
[Music]
like Betty I just I love I love Betty
really yeah like I'm gonna be Veronica
in that house with that scary man like
that's true and then also like having to
own a business like it seems like a lot
of pressure but she puts it on herself
right but I'm saying that in Cheryl's
goals she just is like there that she's
just there and like she just has like
multiple homes that keep being rebuilt
somehow some way yeah
but like she doesn't get that much
anytime so why would I that's true um
what are your future goals after your
internship I know and also like do you
think I know right and right now you're
in a really good place like you have a
lot of experience for a college senior
so just keep doing what you're doing
yeah I am and let the chips fall where
they may
what is your favorite Taylor Swift album
Oh speak now great answer uh who's your
top celebrity you'd love to see on the
toast to see I'm the toast like
realistic yeah okay um I think I know
your answer probably let me echo power
yeah yeah that's and that's realistic
that's totally realistic mm-hmm um what
is here
what was your mood when you had to leave
Jackie um no mo earlier than everyone
else oh my god it was pure and utter
torture it was like so sad and so
annoying and like everyone was like
still like not really I don't think you
guys really partying but you guys were
just like drinking by the pool and nice
and like I was in the library and I was
like bow like this is really like school
again you had to do this yeah I missed
the vacation day of the try which is
like I needed more than the dying part
of the trip but um I did leave having
made a lot of money gambling so like who
knows what would have happened if I
stayed
oh that's you you made money yes you
mean 100 Oh congratulations
I'm so happy free we didn't know that
yeah and I'm glad like you left before I
would like I never saw you leave so I I
would have like been so upset I didn't
say about it's just like I woke up it
was gone okay and I had to just move on
yeah
what are your top three favorite country
songs oh um like I live like you were
dying
it's up there yeah this is like all-time
favorite yeah live like you were dying
it's so hard so ours is there so many
different moods to like sad country or
like let's [ __ ] go country right I
just feel like tequila like yeah is
there and then like a Rascal Flatts song
mm-hmm like um yours if you want it no
like I've been loving what's that song
where you are yeah love also fast cars
in freedom also like Oh their whole
catalogue here comes good bye also my
wish like
yes what is the number one quality
you're looking for in a guy if you could
just like I don't know like me that'd be
great but you're so easy to love snitch
what I think you need to be more Pig
like what what's the most important
thing I do you want someone funny smart
who teaches you new things I want
something smart and funny but I'm cute
but a little bit nerdy okay that's good
yeah so what's the number one of those
um who's smart or funny or cute can be
cute I can't be funny but like don't be
dumb do you mean it'd have to be genius
no but honestly it's it it goes head and
ass yeah like it's hard to be funny when
you're not like a funny person is
usually smart because it takes smarts to
be funny yeah would you rather be a
giant hamster or a tiny rhino I wouldn't
want to be a giant anything but like a
giant hamster
like if you're a tiny rabbit oh I feel
like someone like is gonna step on you
that's true if you're giant like if
you're a giant hamster then people are
scared of you and I'd rather instill
fear than die that's true so you're
gonna go giant mm-hmm giant hamster
what'd you do I think tiny rhymin right
now because like hamsters and he's gonna
tail like that like just freaks me out
okay last song which is a great one if
you could have less song sorry last
question is a great one before we get
into dynasty if you could only pregame
with one song what would it be oh [ __ ]
um I could only premium to oneself
we're actually note I'm gonna change the
question a little banks if like if there
was one song that played every time you
walked into the room like your theme
song what would it be oh it's so hard on
the spot like my theme song I feel like
I'd probably be like a Little Mix song
mm-hmm how that's my ex now that is like
that's giving your ex too much play
totally black magic black magic or like
Oh a Jessica Lynne song yeah I don't
know that's really that's really hard
okay you can think about it I'll think
about it anyways
now it is time for dynasty I hope all of
you are caught up I caught up last night
but let's give them like five seconds if
you're not to like I hope you enjoy the
show bye yeah Oh bye thank you all for
watching
at Jackie O problems where can everyone
follow you or go Marga a straight body
by snitch but we're gonna talk about
dying to see but if you haven't watched
it okay turtle dynasty season last
week's episode oh my god like every
episode is just like there's a twist and
a turn and it's like I just I don't know
how the writers are doing it but like
it's just so who's even writing it I
don't know I don't know anything the
writing is so good like balance insults
on point oh the whole thing when she
yelled at Susan Sarandon that was Susan
Sarandon wasn't I I don't think so it
just looks like her no no cuz I'm pretty
sure she posted before the episode was
like so honored to like work with and I
was like oh my god really I think so no
it was Susan Sarandon oh wow okay I
missed that um I just like the Eman
Fallon our end game for me like I'm so
obsessed with them and I know everyone
like loves founding kool hain jo today
but most people Lea more kool hain I
feel like Kristin is Colleen I text her
after every single thing and I'm like
how could you still be but also like
less we forget like kool hain in the
last episode of the first season was
like ready to get back at the
Carrington's for to avenge his father's
death like come hell or high water so
like I feel like he's using Fallon to do
that and he's being like weirdly down
for her even when in the first season he
was giving her [ __ ] for everything she
ever did like Liam only ever loved her
for who she was and Liam saw the worst
of an error like Liam only saw her Liam
never even saw her in good times cuz she
was only with him in bad times and he
still loved her and accepted her like
Colleen was always yelling at Fallon for
the things that she does that are just
natural to her and like she shouldn't
have to change for anyone let alone a
man I couldn't agree more
and like he was always so mean to her
last season now we're supposed to
believe it he just did this like magical
switch and he's just such an amazing guy
like I'm sick
well did you did you pick up on how they
were like calling each other
foul hain yeah that was weird that is
weird but like but like I don't know
like and also that when they were like
in the bed together Liam and like I just
I like she was looking amazing tits out
for the boy
tits out for the boys who watch the show
with their fiance's thank you writers
for that because like we'd like now
example now you have to watch the show
with me yeah oh my god like I just love
them and the whole like tennis of it all
like I just was a living
the look so you don't have to follow
dynasty closet oh my god stop yeah okay
everything that they wear and it's just
like everything they wear is like don't
you hate that
Gucci everything is still change Jean
like I just like and like I just I love
it so much I'm like oh the ending the
ending will get the crystal of it all
oh the crystal of it all and also just
like the dedication to the glamour like
the set the tennis courts in the homes
like I just I love it we don't get that
anymore everything is like sadness and
fake sets and like studios yeah and this
is like they actually film in Atlanta
mm-hmm it's a real home it's a home but
like it's also a set it's weird inside
but like that tennis court is clear like
you know they're filming on site
somewhere and like they're just giving
us the most and even the New York scenes
we're so glamorous it was really getting
me like Gossip Girl by say and like the
private jet like I just can't do crystal
of it all this is what we were saying
last night because as she's in the main
picture promo for when you click Dinah
and watch so the cheese me whatever and
so like not Nathalie Kelly no Natalie
Kelly left dynasty who knows whose
choice that was and she's really bad
actress so I'm not but I really like I'd
like to like her I liked your character
I liked her like I liked her outfit I
liked but like she was she was not good
at her job
okay kind of fair but she left and the
CW dynasty had had a chance to pick a
new lead actress and and they chose this
girl who's now playing crystal Jennings
and I while I don't dislike her it's
just like well that's gonna like where
you have we have Liz Gillies we have
Nicollette Sheridan and we have you I
don't know I'm not seeing it I'm not
seeing it yet
but I do like like her character but
it's like our characters trying to be
there for everyone but she's also like
what about if she's manipulative she is
she doesn't know these people is she so
she never knew crystal no because
remember like a thief I was just
watching them yeah I think so I don't
know it's really weird but like Blake is
for someone who's supposed to be such a
like boss like makes such stupid
decisions like all the time and the toy
cars thing was so dumb oh so dumb and
like his like big fit at that party but
it's like big time
I was here for it because like it's true
his wife died and everyone's like
yelling at him when he was going around
the world setting up charities no one
even asked him how he was doing that's
true that's sure but like that's just
not how they do things in the Carrington
fan that's sure and like eBay that he
doesn't ask people how they are doing so
you reap what you sow that's true sis
that's true but the ending the ending so
Steven is not a Carrington as son of
Anders like that was just such a plot
twist because like Anders and Blake's
friendship has been like the only like
concrete thing of like the whole show
and like now like that's gonna be in
jeopardy and like at first when we were
supposed to think it was Fallon who
wasn't a Carrington I was like I'm not
watching this show anymore yeah I get
that wasn't a Carrington like there's no
point there's I have no reason to be
here but then with Stephen it's like I'm
okay with it but I'm probably now that
balance of sole heir like what could be
better
founds the sole heir to Blake's fortune
and Stephen never even wanted to be
accounting you know what you finally got
what you wanted like you don't like the
life living in the lap of luxury you
don't like the excess you don't want
your child to be brought up in it by the
way you don't have a child anymore and
there you got you what you wanted but
honestly did you have to say when he all
that stuff was happening and he was like
like what like that was he did grave
like that was a great what like and I
can't believe that like Lily van der
Woodsen just like gave up her secret
that quick like I thought it was gonna
take like the episodes of finding out
like cuz she clearly wasn't having his
baby but I thought we would have to
really soothe so like also not even just
that like yeah but you think I like they
would do a DNA test at the like when the
baby's born
yeah I'm sure they would also do it in
utero but it's it's like it's invasive
it is invasive so like I know so her guy
knows the dad so he could have fudged
the papers and I knows the dad right I
forgot about that that whole thing like
went by in two seconds like and there's
so many other things that I was worried
about I didn't really care right and
Nicollette Sheridan was like shook and
pissed but then she was like well they
she got what she wanted in one respect
which is that should not be added yeah
but also like I kind of weird lead like
like Kirby like I don't like doing and
she's like being annoying but like I
think she's like really pretty and cute
and I think that if her and Fallon like
in some way became friends like I would
be really down for that yeah I may be
we're headed there I hope so but like
now I hope Allan needs better friends
and what's Jeff's sister's name Monica
I don't know but I think we're so quick
to turn on Fallon like Talan you need
better friend she's not a real friend no
at all Cole Haynes always quick to turn
on Fallon like everyone just always sees
the worst in Fallon it's like all town
wants to do is just elevate everyone's
lives give a girl a break I love her and
Liam and she loves him
I think I think they might be endgame
the two of them because like clearly
something shady is going on with kool
hain and like Liam's gonna be there for
her and like if she just stays married
to LeAnn like in her heart and mentally
physically and spiritually all of her
life problems are solved right and like
I don't know why she doesn't realize
that like there's nothing great about
kool hain no but like they just have
history I know but like and I think
count Fallon like really does want to
get away from you know like her family
and wants to start her own family and
like Liam was just more family drama you
know like she would be marrying into my
daughter I think that she doesn't like
wants to stop what she's doing I think
the whole team is trying to get her to
do that but like she like she was born
to be like the boss of a billion-dollar
company but she could create her own
it's just a matter of which
billion-dollar company she's gonna be
the boss of her own or but now that
Blake is like back and better like they
don't have to sell the company any right
that's true and I like when Blake and
foul and get along me too and I liked
when Ellen and crystal got along meet
you and also I don't know how I feel
about Alexis like I don't know if I'm
supposed to like her I just don't get it
I think we have to get used to her
because I think you don't she definitely
there she's here too I think in the
beginning she was just a guest and I
really didn't like her and I was ready
for her to go but now that I know she's
just gonna be around also she was being
helpful in trying to like get Kirby out
like to in protecting Fallon yeah so as
long as you're protecting our girl
you can stay also it's so weird and
protecting Stephen and trying to get
Lilly dinner what's into admit because
I'm watching Desperate Housewives ball
dynasty's on so I'm like switching
between Edie Britt but she's adolescent
it's the same person it's really funny
but yeah I think that's I think that's
it I think what else TV I'm so behind on
Real Housewives just because like it's
nothing
compelling like when New York housewives
were on it took over the culture like
Giovanni
took over the world if I hadn't seen
that episode when it aired I would have
watched it immediately because
everybody's talking about it like
nobody's talking about the
see nobody's really talking about Dallas
like I'll catch up when I catch up and
then Riverdale you're like I said I'm
not watching weeks week anymore because
it's just it's confusing it's spooky and
then by the time I get into it it's over
and I want to watch them like three or
four out of time did you see the
jailbreak seen the jailhouse but dancing
no oh the Vixen yeah at the football
game that oh yeah that wasn't me and
then they all get beat up later it's
getting like so crazy I'm really like
I'm only really watching now not for the
plot but for the characters just because
I love them agreed but like I hope
something changes I don't know how to
say that because like I'm a die-hard
Riverdale but like I'm really not into
where what's going I know it's so sad
like right Oh Ross if you're watching
I'm really sorry I don't know if write
or watch Ross watches the toast but he
was a big after Dale fan yeah and those
outer Dale fans they're they're strong
they're really sure you'll comment on
the after Airedale Instagram and like a
youtuber like please don't anything but
after that like please don't take away
our after day like they're so Claudia
and I on patreon we've read all the
comments out loud like we were so shook
by how much people loved it considering
we hated doing it except I think if we
walked back old episodes now it actually
is really funny no we're so tired but
they were so tired it was so funny it's
just we're we're funny bunch of a bunch
of people yeah
have you started Sabrina the Teenage
Witch no because I don't like watching
two shows at once so I'm waiting to
finish desperate before I do that are
you almost done with desperate yeah Mon
season say is it not the greatest show
of all time
it's a greatest show of our generation
like there's so many things that I
forgot like I'm left to matty mckibben
from awkward he's on it now even if you
watched it back in the day if you watch
it again it's a whole name it's a whole
new show and like I've deeper
understandings of the characters now
yeah do you don't Amy is there just like
olenek grows on you by the way but in
the beginning she's so annoying like
always complaining but like she's
low-key like so funny like she's like
she's a Miranda yeah she's a hundred
percent the Miranda absolutely
absolutely despise Susan like nothing
more to say about that and Bree like
there's so much I forgot about her right
now I'm not gonna okay
that's the best and I think that was
like her one true love you think well
I'm honestly at the beginning of it so I
forgot that I don't know that they like
okay no no but I mean whatever and I
basically
I don't know I love Gabby and Carla I
love Bree and like brie was so
misunderstood like all brie wants me it
was just like help her children help her
family like get things done but I love
that like Andrew made a turnaround yeah
and now he's like a great announcer any
sports or business does she have yeah
yeah that's at the five years later part
her business is amazing
and she no one deserves it more than her
I love you know totally um and I really
love Gaby and Carlos like in the
beginning like she's annoying cuz she's
making stupid decisions and like blah
blah blah blah also not appreciating her
and loving writing there glutes her back
to like in perfect harmony like I love
them I love her and I need a waa and ITA
yes that was so funny I didn't even
think about it and then like everyone
was like you're spelling it wrong and I
was like [ __ ] she spell Banita waa and
ITA when it's Ju Ju a and ITA it's funny
that not wander yeah but I learn in
school that's so funny oh my gosh it's
already been an hour in 20 minutes
snitch thank you for being the hostess
with the mostess and always just being
available when called on but usually but
usually like we Claudia is not here here
usually with her cuz you're on tour
that's true but today was a special day
and Claudia will be act tomorrow so
it'll be the toast as usual we'll hit up
some dear toasters you'll be here so
it'll be a real full episode of the
toast
we'll be here for the rest of the
Halloween tomorrow's our Halloween
episode spooky so stay tuned for what
we're gonna do I have to go text Claudia
and we'll be back tomorrow
where can everyone follow the snitch I
reckon follow me at more gosh ray and
body my snitch even though she's been a
little like low lately it's just like
I've so many other things going on that
like she had to take a back seat but
hopefully I'll get her back up in high
management time management but like
there's so much so much time to manage
yeah agreed
you only have the same amount of hours
in the day which bothers Jenner yeah
which is just there's so many actually
are so many hours in a day I've come to
learn but sometimes there's just no but
sometimes it's just like I refuse to
wake up that early to utilize them
yesterday I woke up at 3 o'clock yes but
I had to but I didn't get home until
3:30 a.m. so I needed a 12-hour sleep to
recoup from the weekend and that
required waking up at 3 o clock and it
happens you guys also went to bed at
12:30 so you just I went to bed at 12:30
last night so
you were just awake for like not that
much time I managed to eat a lot not
really um I like I thought I just ate so
much candy when I got home oh you did
anything that I had in my apartment that
was remotely like tasty I ate it Oh fine
whatever it's fine anyways thank you all
so much for tuning and you can follow me
at rakia problems for the most premium
content at the morning toast we go live
on Facebook and Instagram no we don't
Facebook and YouTube every Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
and then we are available as a podcast
starting on November 27th we are
switching to only YouTube so if you
watch on Facebook get used to watching
on YouTube because it is way more
premium have an amazing day everyone
Tootles bye
you